all right Aaron Aaron tchaikovsky nice
to have you here man I really really
appreciate it thank you for taking the
time thank you for inviting me yeah I
found out your stuff I found out about
your work through mark who we had on the
podcast as well and I just really really
appreciate you taking the time you're
only in LA for three days so thank you
again pleasure yeah yeah looking forward
to talking to you about my work and
filling you with lots of imagery of
animals suffering which everyone wants
on a Tuesday morning right it's gonna be
all the cheery stuff today yeah I mean
well it's it's it's interesting cuz like
your work is very it's is visceral and
it gets a reaction but it's not like at
least from my perspective it's not like
oh my god I can't I can't look at that I
can at least look at it and be like wow
I really feel you know for for these
animals that's good to hear because um
that is something that I kind of battle
with is that people have enough misery
in their lives like they don't just want
to see shots of animal suffering so you
have to kind of draw the line and if
something is too upsetting if something
is too gory then people just simply
won't look at it so I think and I
actually think that some of these images
have a kind of makar beauty to them as
well
mm-hmm so I want to feel you know I want
people to be compelled to actually look
at my imagery but then to learn more
about the story I think you can see some
of the images here which are some of my
favorite shots on on the homepage yeah
this shot of shrimps and bycatch you
know I think it looks like a an abstract
painting this orangutan here at a boxing
match and you know it has this giant
noble beasts surrounded by this kind of
beautiful man-made structure and I think
these are images personally that I I'd
like to blow up blow up and show them
big which is what we were talking about
before yeah yeah it drives me absolutely
insane how everyone digests photography
these days on these you know tiny little
phones yeah these images have to be
shown large where which is why I like to
print them yeah but most people won't
see them they'll never see them that
size
and it drives me slightly mad social
media does in general in fact but I know
it's a necessary evil we can we can talk
about this if you want and I can run for
the next hour and a half just about
social media well I mean actually we
probably want to talk about something
more interesting rather than look at not
know I think it's all I think it's
really all good stuff I am in total
agreeance with you like as a filmmaker
you know the short films that I've made
I put a lot of time and a lot of effort
into the final product and to have it
viewed on the phone is kind of like are
you really getting the full effect of
the artwork you know you know you're
taking away like if you look like say
one of your images right you blow it up
real big and you're standing in front of
it she's like wow this is it's Brett
it's actually breathtaking you know and
you have a chance to get kind of wrapped
in the aura of the art right but then
you shrink it down like this and it's
just like a side thought you know what's
this
squirrel squirrel squirrel squirrel
squirrel oh that's cool I guess squirrel
squirrel squirrel and that's it you know
you don't have a chance to like meditate
on it exactly and and because we are so
inundated with imagery these days and
because phones take such good photos
really um so you know if you were to go
out there and take a landscape shot of
what I was just saying went to Joshua
Tree National Park I mean taking shots
on my phone that actually look you know
really good yeah and if you only see
them on a phone screen it doesn't look
that different to something that you
would take on on my 5d Mark four it's
really when you start blowing images up
to their full size that you can start to
appreciate them properly so how do you
how do you how do you dish out your
photography to people like you have an
Instagram oh yeah yeah I'm not I'm not
very good using it I don't I don't
understand it very well I have you know
for followers and now I have more than
that actually I yeah yes you gonna
follow me okay yeah 20% more Facebook
has been a pretty big thing for me yeah
I get a lot of engagement from my posts
on Facebook so I put a story up recently
about this
Turtle Conservation Center in Bali
mm-hmm I think these turtles are the
most like appalling conditions
imaginable then they had snakes with
their mouths taped shots and oh I just
absolutely hideous
and I put the images on Facebook on my
professional page Aaron tchaikovsky
environmental photojournalist there it
is
and I think they've reached 1.7 million
people you know very very quickly so I
do have quite kind of loyal following on
Facebook and I know that if I put out a
powerful story that it's gonna get
shared a lot and seen by a lot of people
but be not against the the fact that
Facebook is definitely becoming less
popular I think now and I know that
platforms like Instagram are probably
the way to go but I find them very hey I
find them it's Instagram so so shallow
it's just you know shots of people
looking hot
which is great yeah you know it's good
for escapism for you know 30 seconds a
day um but I find actually for serious
material like mine Instagram isn't a
very good platform for me and Facebook
you can you know you can share articles
you get much more comments and
engagement and I just find that that's
maybe I'm a dinosaur I don't know I
think that at some point there will be a
better platform that comes available for
photographers okay at the moment we
don't have had anything that is quite
perfect that's a good point
that's a good point and especially for
your work too which is more serious and
yeah there's like a huge message behind
your stuff mmm you know like that the
photography I post on on my Instagram is
just like a cool scenery or whatever
there's not really more to it than that
yeah it's I think yeah that's it I think
Instagram can be quite kind of quite
vacuous I guess and people just go on
there for a little bit of escapism
throughout that day to look at a hot
girl yeah actually they don't want to go
to Instagram to learn anything serious
or to be educated about animal welfare
issues yeah so I mean at least at the
end of the day like you have your
Facebook page and it is a platform for
you to put out your stuff and like grow
an awareness you know for people and by
hey this is a thing you know these
animals are being treated in this way
these different countries like take a
look at this you know people are
actually able to sink into that a little
bit you know yeah yes good exactly
exactly so it is there and I can use it
but I've the way I kind of prefer to get
my message out there is through
different mediums so it's whether it's
film
so I also make environmental films
magazines you know big competitions
competitions have been a great way to
get the message out there I won Wildlife
Photographer for the year two years ago
I think it was for a shot that's on my
homepage there of elephants in a palm
oil plantation and the amount of
awareness that that image created was
just incredible I had images from I mean
emails from people all over the world
who said like I didn't even know that
Borneo had elephants let alone the fact
that there's only 1500 of them left and
that they're threatened with extinction
they're like I knew everything about
orangutans from Borneo but yeah nothing
about the elephant situation yeah this
is this is all new to me this is all
like I don't really know much about this
kind of stuff well this is the power of
photography yeah that it really is such
a powerful educational tool so look you
know I try and use as many different
means to get the message out there as as
possible because that's kind of touched
upon earlier conservation is one of
those very tricky subjects and everyone
like when you go and you speak to
broadcasters so at the moment we're in
the middle of pitching to conservation
series so I've been working on to
broadcast pilots for a different series
so one of them is about the exotic pet
trade and one of them is about wildlife
tourism industry which is about this
campaign called raise the red flag that
I've been working on for the last two
years and you're going out there and I
had a meeting with Netflix main
production company in Bristol recently
they kind of looked at me like they were
like oh this is a very nice idea like
their most kind of patronizing voice
like well done you've been you know in
the jungle making these important shows
but Netflix they want cute and cuddly
now so that's that's what we're up
against is that
yeah conservation has kind of
traditionally be seen
word in the media is depressing or it's
boring or it's anoraks I think things
are changing which was why it was so
surprising for me to hear that amount
Netflix is though it does seem that you
know people really are getting into
conservation but again it comes back to
that fact that a lot of the time people
want to turn on the television because
they they want escapism and they don't
want to be bombarded with more
negativity so what you try and do
particularly in our films is they it
can't just be negativity throughout it
has to have some hope at the ending so
this film that we've been working on
about orangutan tourism which is the
pilot for for this series that on raise
the red flag so we've been looking at
the very worst orangutan tourism
operators from that you know the worse
news to places where they're forced to
perform and box each other to places
where they're out in the wild and people
are feeding them and like it's just an
absolute [ __ ] show yeah actually can we
pull up the picture of the orangutan
with the boxing gloves and you have a
couple photos of that right I do yeah
yeah and if you go to my yeah galleries
and then you go to wildlife tourism and
there was another image further down of
welcome for me there's nothing like you
know an emaciated orangutan in a bikini
to kind of get people feeling something
right sure yeah and this is why I've
never been that interested in
traditional wildlife photography I don't
I don't want to go and take a photograph
of an orangutan in a tree eating fruit
that's like everywhere everyone does
that meaningless it's meaningless but
actually yeah you take a shot of one in
a in a boxing ring being exploited and
and and also it's creating something
that is completely unique and I know
that a lot of the images that you're
you're scrolling through now shots like
this have not been taken before and
that's what excites me so much about it
yeah so these are so this is the last
two years I have been traveling around
the world documenting cruelty in the
wildlife tourism industry
I started in Thailand a couple of years
just because I'd been living in Borneo
where I was presenting wildlife shows in
Borneo and had just seen a lot of these
terrible zoos and performances so I've
got a little bit of money from a private
donor and said look I want to go to
Thailand and explore it properly went
there documented it including the boxing
orangutans and and various hideous zoos
and and you know just a lot of the
places that were actually covered in a
NatGeo article recently hmm
release into the media and they just
they went everywhere because wildlife
tourism is is one of those issues I
think that it really affects everyone
like there's not a single person here
here in this studio today that wouldn't
have been to a zoo would have been to an
aquarium that wouldn't have you know
maybe ridden on an elephant at some
point everyone is affected by wildlife
tourism so that's why it it became and
I'm sort of slowly realized when I got
that kind of outpouring from the public
and I got so many people contacting me
from around the world is that this was a
much bigger issue than I had thought so
that was when I started to go and
investigate it in other different
countries yeah as a photojournalist and
then I also realized that there wasn't a
platform so people could allow their
voices to be heard so a lot of the time
people would get in touch with me and
they would say well I've seen this
terrible place what would I do about it
who do I go to can I report it somewhere
and there wasn't anything available to
people so I came up with the idea to
create a platform called raise the red
flag so it meant that you could you can
go online and if you see an animal being
abused in the wildlife tourism industry
then you can make a report so built the
platform and then went to Born Free
Foundation and you do you know that no I
I don't I just want to just just take
one step back so when you say make a
report who's the report sent to well
that was said the report would then come
through to a central moderator who would
then have the necessary necessary skills
to be able to
they actually you know this isn't this
isn't right something needs to be done
we need to go and investigate this we
need to work with the authorities to
help this animal so that was where where
I started to become unstuck because I
was like I showed it to to a lot of
colleagues and friends and said what do
you think of this idea and they were
like it's a great idea but what happens
when you start getting hundreds or
thousands of reports what are you going
to do with them that's right yes you
know that's pretty good point I don't
know yeah which is a major which is a
major stumbling block because I'm a I'm
a photographer like I'm not yeah I'm
into animal welfare but I'm not trained
in it I'm not a zoologist
I'm not biologists yeah yeah so that was
there not I was like right okay well
maybe I need to work with an NGO who can
actually take over this side of things
hmm so I went and I spoke to Born Free
foundation who had actually commissioned
me to go to some other places to
document abuse in the wildlife tourism
industry and I said look you know this
platform has been built why do you guys
take it on and continue sending me off
to different destinations around the
world to do what I do best which is
photographing cool
so they said great you know they were
looking to overhaul their their
reporting system anyway they love the
idea they love the brand and they took
it on and spend kind of 18 months
populating the site and then we had a
big launch in London in August and we
have various celebrity patrons on board
and the platform has got a lot of
publicity and I really think that Born
Free have the expertise and resources to
take the platform to the next level
because uh I simply don't and I don't
have the will to do it I don't have the
knowledge for sure yeah no it sounds
like you did a really good job with like
combining your passion of photography
with something that the world needs you
know an awareness for you know this
abuse that goes on with animals in this
industry so like where does the where's
the line drawn is it like any zoo is bad
or like you know what I was in I was in
Bali Monkey Forest you know
like they were you know this is a big ol
area in the middle of ubud and they were
swinging from trees and like getting
bananas and having a good time so like
you know like that
wouldn't that be how do you know you
have to really dig in and investigate or
is it something that like as a tourist
you go and you see it and you're like
whoa that's kind of jacked up
yeah that's pretty open yeah it's it's
very hard to know yeah and this is one
of the problems that we're facing is
well first of all there's there's a lot
of greenwashing that goes on so there
are so many places around the world that
that call themselves conservation
centers and it is utter [ __ ] like it
could not be further from the from the
truth and they just use it to as a way
of getting people through the door and
and to make money money so how do you
know which of the good place in which
are the bad ones well that's difficult
that's partly where raise the red flag
comes in and if it's if it's on there
then it's a place that you shouldn't go
and visit that there are kind of general
rules when it comes to wildlife tourism
so any places where you can touch an
animal or get close enough to take a
selfie with it or if you can ride it or
if it's used in performances then you
shouldn't go that makes sense to me like
circuses circuses yep absolute no-go and
places are starting to catch up in in
England and they're banning animals used
in circuses but I've just been on a tour
around Europe for the NGO for pause to
document wildlife tourism attractions
around Europe because yeah it's very
easy sometimes the scapegoats like
Southeast Asian countries and say oh
this is just happening this is just
happening in Asia and you know and then
you have that kind of white Savior thing
of going in and saying no this is bad
you shouldn't be doing that whereas
actually it's happening all over the
world it's happening right here in
America it's happening in England it's
happening all over Europe so I just went
and documented like you know elephant
riding in in Germany there was a circus
in the Czech Republic that was like
horrendous had of like this really
malnourished bear on a skateboard it had
lions that were being whipped and you
know used performance
it had zebra it had camels and that's at
a traveling circus in the Czech Republic
and if if these are the things that you
see with your own eyes imagine what's
happening
try scenes yeah behind closed doors
totally and we saw some of the trailers
where the animals are kept I do think I
have an image of this actually I've got
some some shots if you go back to the
gallery you can see some some imagery
from this recent trip yeah this one yes
this gallery so if you scroll down
oh yeah look there's the Lions you can
see them up up a bit go up yeah and on
the right there and these at these lions
were just they were seriously unhappy
and if you scroll to the left that's
then this was an elephant that was used
in a circus in Germany dang well oh yeah
that's another image on the left of
elephants used in the Czech Republic in
a circus so one down yeah there's just
like these puppets you know just like
these yeah yes things to be yeah don't
know why mankind feels that why do we
feel like everything every other living
being is just there for us to either
exploit or to enjoy and that oh that's
the show yeah hang a town in the bikini
the middle that one nature photographer
of the year last yeah that one's crazy
yeah emotional emotional shot so yeah so
yeah it's is happening absolutely
everywhere and it's I do think that
people are starting to take these issues
more seriously and that is where the
media plays a very important role to
start taking more interest in some of
these stories how'd you get in all this
how did I get into it well I'm a trained
as a copywriter so I worked in London
for publishing companies in my early 20s
and then I started a modeling agency
with my best mate from school did that
for four or five years which was you
know good fun in your in your mid-20s
mmm-hmm
but then more and more I started to kind
of look in the mirror and not like what
I saw I think that's that's physically
you know my my skin was getting more
sort of orange and my my hair more
bleach to my teeth whiter but that was
also I kind of couldn't didn't want to
live with doing that anymore as such a
shallow industry do you surf I don't
know okay I don't because abyss art I
could see that I could see you surfing
right it's you surfing I love
description yeah no no I actually don't
I don't it takes up too much time
it'd be it'd be a lot yeah yeah exactly
so I then yeah I decided okay like I'd
always loved wildlife films and I
thought if I'm gonna make a major change
in my life I was in my late twenties
this is the time to do it so I yeah I
went to bed one night and sleep a wink
and I was like why I'm doing I'm leaving
and I went off around the world and
started diving and then started looking
into more into marine conservation and
then I went into the wildlife filmmaking
course in South Africa and then I went
to Mozambique bought myself an
underwater camera and housing went alone
underwater film in Mozambique medical
guys making a documentary on shark
finning and then spent a couple years
living living in Mozambique making this
film just fascinating like for the first
time in my life it was like I actually
kind of felt alive and I was learning
about the ocean and about conservation
and about diving and about living in
Africa and it was just yeah it's just
like a sponge kind of absorbing
everything did you feel like you had a a
purpose or was it just a passion that
that you felt at that time oh yeah both
I suddenly yeah I felt like this is um
sounds a bit cliched or a bit corny but
I thought like this is what I'm meant to
be doing with my life
and that feeling hasn't changed this was
ten years ago I still feel this every
single day
I'm incredibly like there's not that
many people who can say I have found
what I meant to do I know I was meant to
and I will do this for the rest of my
life that's amazing unless I haven't
nervous nervous breakdown first
it could easily happen but even given
even if you do I feel like you would
still there'd still be like a spark you
know or a passion to pursue you know at
some point right you sounds it sounds
like you found your calling yeah I think
yeah I think I have and what um what I'm
so lucky with is that this so many I
shouldn't say lucky that's really the
wrong word but there's so many stories
out there that need more exposure so I'm
constantly working across different
species in different countries and
continents and the far corners of the
earth Wow to document these issues so I
feel like I can never get bored you know
I'm just let's get organizing a well
I'll give you an example like I'm
currently on a trip four months away
I've been to 16 countries so far across
all continents working on three
different broadcast films at the moment
and then currently organizing projects
through to you know May next next year
so it's really really busy which is
great it's it's not without its
downsides it's very tiring it's very
stressful working sometimes in dangerous
situations um probably not great on your
mental health and you don't get any
stability like I'm constantly living out
of a bag um it would be nice to at least
I'm 39 like I was just joking to my
friend I don't own any keys like I'm a
39 year old who has no keys surely like
it's um even too you know a biker or
something but no I don't have one I mean
that sounds kind of cool though you know
like you're not to worry about any of
that stuff it does yeah it does it does
sound cool I guess in a way but it's um
it can be unsettled unsettling so I've
got used to it now like I I'm now used
to the fact that you just pack and move
you know ya a moment's notice
but it's that's not to say that it
doesn't take its toll what do you do to
relax what do you do to chill and like I
drink whiskey okay what kind and
anything that's put in front of me yeah
people always say like how do you cope
with these um slightly distressing
projects that you work on I'm like well
I have my my therapist on speed dial and
a bottle of whiskey in the other hand
they kind of balance each other out
so to relax I suppose I you know man I
don't love it because it's it's been so
crazy that you're just going from
projects project to project I guess you
know I'll go and try and go home to the
UK and see my family
they just scooped me up it was a couple
of months ago I came back from from the
jungles of Borneo to this film on a
Ranga tan tourism mm-hmm I think just
pick me up from the airport
they were like what has happened to you
oh man I come home sit on the couch and
we're just gonna feed you and like yo
you're gonna sleep because it's so like
you're working you know really 16-hour
days in the jungle like non-stop travel
we've just been just taking us four days
to travel across Indonesia on public
transport because we're always you know
we have the small budgets for things you
know we're trying to cut corners
carrying like you know sixty kilos of
luggage each on planes trains
automobiles public transport you know
and we were traveling for four days
across Indonesia for one interview Wow
and it's exhausting it's really really
tiring but like I shouldn't really
complain because um you know when
there's nothing else in the world I'd
rather be doing but just sometimes you
need to go and you need to then just
like lock yourself away from the world
and just completely de-stress absolutely
absolutely I'm big into yoga and trying
to meditate meditating is very difficult
it is it is very like the hardest thing
yeah cut your mind off don't think about
anything I'm like but I want to think
about things yeah I like thinking about
the things that they're telling me not
think about I know I know but no I
agreed like you need some way of yeah
just completely cutting off yeah whether
that's whether it's exercise whether
it's reading whether it's movies that
you you can't just immerse yourself in
these subjects
all the time um so now you're gonna have
to give me some tips about meditating
for sure I just know a little little bit
of stuff I read one book once and I
practice and I did yoga teacher training
and that was about it
okay that's good but stop yeah I mean
from what I gather it's just like a
muscle you know you know one wants to
work out like working out kind of sucks
yeah at the end of when you're done it's
like oh great I feel awesome you know I
did it it was hard and I went through it
and it's like like it's the same with
meditating like you just got to be like
this kind of sucks
then you got to get into that flow and
and then afterwards it's worth it's nice
yeah and you take a breath in and I feel
like I can slow down now yeah yeah I
think I'm opposed to it as well cuz I
have been living in Bali a little bit
and there are like so many of these like
yogi kind of like meditators who walk
around in their elephant pants dude I
and then they like take pictures of
themselves like being so spiritual yeah
don't like if this is meant to be such a
personal thing then why the hell are you
like in your underwear on a rock like
meditating and telling all of your
vacuous followers about it like oh sorry
I was saying I wasn't gonna get into
this subject again it's fine it's fine
it's fine usual yeah I was in Bali for a
yoga retreat for like 10 days and some
of these people were like that yeah
there's some of these people for sure
and like it was it was cool though like
we were in ubud like they're like simply
yoga like area and Christians actually
going later later this year too so he's
amped about it oh you're gonna be in
elephant hunts in no time
dude I bought elephant pants I bought
elephant pants I straight-up bought out
but I they didn't fit after work and go
no I'm going I'm out of here I was like
I can get into the elephant pant vibe
right now it was really comfy but man it
was it was a good time I think the most
like the most intense thing though that
happened when I was there we we went to
these different I forget the name of I
forget the name of the communities but
basically there's like all these little
communities of homes and families and
you know they're all off kind of on the
side of the road and they're they're old
they look like each one it's a temple
and we went into one and we were
bringing eggs coffee and rice
two families that couldn't afford that
and I was like okay this will be
interesting see what's going down here
and we did it three times and on the
second one we went to this family man
and it was like this mning at of this
concrete cube and like in the back
corner in the dark there was like one
cot on the ground and there was four or
five kids grandma grandpa mom and dad
and one of the kids was mentally
challenged and I was like oh my god this
is so rough this is so rough but I
looked at them and like they they looked
happy you know and we brought them the
stuff we brought them to eggs and the
rice and the coffee and like the grandma
started crying dude I couldn't handle it
it was it was sad it was sad for sure
and and I'm standing there just like
trying to take it in you know just
trying to take the moment in and and
then the group is like yo let's get a
picture with them let's get a picture
with them and I was like I'm good I'm
good and they all got together and like
took a picture with everybody like as a
grandma was crying and like holding zigs
I'm like guys no no no no pictures like
let's just children and then they want
to send it to show it online on social
media and show the good that they've
been doing right pretend like I'm that
I'm sure that may have happened I don't
know exactly what happened after what
they did with those pictures but I was
just like man I I stepped out I was like
I'm not gonna be in that picture it's
kind of awkward but you know I I kind of
there was a tiny part of me that felt
like this family is happy you know
though they have basically nothing
besides themselves you know they have
the family and the community and there
they were able to live on the most
minimal amount of stuff you know and I
thought that was cool I thought that was
really cool
yeah yeah I think so um some of the
there will be other stresses of course
the you know you won't see and you know
like I live I was
Africa for six years and that was often
people come and they would say well
people seem they seem very happy but
actually yeah for example infant
mortalities is through the roof and they
might have lost two children or like
this the stress is a very different
there so I don't know whether it's safe
to say that but what you see on the
outside is actually the the true
reflection of the story Oh certainly not
yeah I think it's yeah there's different
stresses there but for sure I have been
kind of like cut off from some of the
things that we are constantly subjected
to living that and particularly you here
in LA for example and what I experienced
living in London and that constant
pressure to further yourself or to you
know you can do anything you want so
it's constant constantly so then that
leads to discontent because you're
always thinking well like I could do
this or I could do this I could do
something else whereas actually if you
grow up and you know that you will then
go on to do a certain type of job or you
will go on just to work with your family
there's none of that expectations
there's peace in that yeah yeah and I
think some of the mental pressures that
we face are growing up in the in the
Western world and the developed world
are quite intense and that's why I think
you see so many so many mental health
issues particularly amongst kind of our
generation that's interesting you know
instantly striving for something bigger
and better yeah yeah I mean I I feel it
you know I'm here in Los Angeles and I'm
trying to figure out what's the best
thing for my career how do I further
myself how do I make more money and then
you know my parents are in in Georgia
and I hadn't I talked to them maybe once
a month I see them once a year and you
know I'm just thinking like am i selfish
being out here doing this stuff
just for myself you know it's like I got
to survive right you know I eventually
want to get married and have a kid and
and all this but sometimes I feel
selfish you know going for that that
that context in your dream yeah yeah
totally totally and and it's like well
is it gonna be like this when I'm 80
yeah hopefully if I live - yeah
possibly it could be yeah middle-class
cycle of discontent but I think it's I
think it's cool though be you found
something that you love your passion
right and you're you're going with that
and despite how difficult it may be you
know that that's what you need to do and
you're going with it and you love it
still yes yes I do
that's a great constantly challenged by
it and creatively as well I think that
is a big thing to be constantly
stimulated by something and to always
try and grow as a photographer and grow
your I was going to use the word art
form but it sounds a wee bit pretentious
but yeah yeah your artful yeah
constantly learning whether it's from
different photographers or through
YouTube tutorials you constantly keep
having to push the boundaries creatively
absolutely cuz like without a challenge
you're gonna be bored yeah and if it's
too much of a challenge it's you know
you might dip out yeah you know so I
think it's finding that that perfect
challenge in your area you know well
it's a challenge it's a huge challenge
yeah environmental photography like your
moment can be like one second yeah you
miss it and that image is gone or you
get your shot it's like it's not framed
right it's not quite in focus and then
kick I'm constantly kicking myself hmm
and thinking I could have done a better
job and lamenting my my skills as a
photographer which is good and bad
because I think I give myself an
unnecessarily hard time sometimes but
also if you weren't striving for protect
for perfection yes in your work then you
would you would never grow at the same
level same same with you as a filmmaker
right I feel the exact same way it has
to be perfect you're not going to get
there but there is a strive for
perfection in lots of detail exactly
that's a detail exactly with
environmental photography I always say
that there's this four facets that I'm
looking for okay in for a great
environmental photograph okay number one
that's an unusual subject
so we'll use my elephant shot as an
example unusual subject that pygmy
elephants in in Borneo do an important
you can go if you just go back to
galleries there actually might be a
couple of images that fulfil this
criteria at the top environmental yeah
there's that there's a couple of images
that might fulfill this criteria so top
left is the elephant shot this is good
too because the people who the the
people who listen to this podcast you
know they're up-and-coming filmmakers
photographers and creatives so this is
gonna be great for people listening now
you want to have advice and want to get
advice from a professional like yourself
yeah so well first of all yeah can you
find yourself an unusual subject and
here we have 1500 of these animals
endemic to Borneo left are these
subjects displaying some type of
interesting behavior Christian go back
to the and then they'll see the
elephants they are all there they're in
a herd there's three generations here
they're huddled together seemingly
trying to comfort each other and then we
have a dramatic setting and it doesn't
get much more dramatic than this palm
oil plantation that was actually being
replanted it's this desolate desecrated
man-made scene from hell and then we
have some type of appropriate or
dramatic lighting here it's it's very
overcast so the lighting was even we
have these dark clouds on the horizon
and if you can look can combine those
four facets subject behavior setting
lighting then you have images that will
win major awards it's probably only
happened to me probably a handful of
times in my work like if you go back to
the to the gallery to my environmental
gallery how many of those how many of
these images actually fulfill all of
those all of that criteria not that many
maybe oh this is this is a shot I just
took the otic if you just go to the left
this is a shot I really like I took
recently um this is Japan yes is Japan
is making a film about otters in the
exotic pet trade and
like we were saying earlier creating a
completely unique image is one of the
greatest thrills and challenges for an
environmental photographer and I can
guarantee you that no one has ever taken
anything that looks like this photo so
here we have a young girl in a Tokyo
apartment and they have pet otters this
is a bit of a craze in Southeast Asia
that they're keeping otters as exotic
pets despite the fact that officers make
the worst pets possible and often
they've been stolen from the wild the
parents are killed in order to get the
babies I'm so it's really quite a
complex issue and and and the young
child was just you know looking out onto
the city and you have the skyline there
and she was she was just yeah having a
look at the city and then suddenly the
otter ran across the windowsill have all
the child's toys on the left and just
yeah perfect framing so I think that's
yeah that's kind of one of my favorite
images actually my favorite images
always change depending on the job that
I've just been on there are there are a
couple of shots that I've taken that
will always kind of be favorites of mine
but yeah it changes all the time
depending on what I'm working on the one
of the woman diving spearfishing yes
that one is so good oh my goodness like
like that might be under marine
conservation was was that like a candid
photo or did you ever pose and this was
a story yes just down to the left yeah
there that lady that's on my homepage
it's so good so this we made a series
about a year ago called timor-leste from
below actually all of your listeners can
go to WWE birds are TV to see some of
the environmental series that we've made
cool and this was a ten part show all
about Timor Leste or East Timor which is
a tiny little country next to Indonesia
in Southeast Asia absolutely fascinating
place still recovering from war not that
many visitors or tourists at all but has
the most incredible marine resources I'm
actually going to be there
in two weeks leading the photography
tour out there and we're going to see
they have an annual blue whale migration
oh well they have resident sperm whales
they have resident Dewgong they have
thousands of dolphins there's 25
cetacean species just in this small body
of water and there's no other boats
there's no other tourists so you can go
out in the boat and in a single day you
have the opportunity to see yeah blue
whale sperm whales thousands of dolphins
and potentially if you want to than a
dugong in the morning what's a know
what's a dugong do going is it's like a
manatee okay so you're diving in you're
diving in and taking shots like this so
so sorry gun packed that was a very
long-winded way for me to explain this
this photo so on one of the islands off
the coast of Dilli which is the capital
of these Timor there's Nilan called a
Toro which has technically the world's
most biodiverse reef more more fish and
coral species counted by Conservation
International on one dive than anywhere
else on on the planet Wow and they have
this community of females who decided
like they saw all of their partners who
were going out fishing and feeding the
family and making money and they thought
well why can't we do this as well so
they formed a group called the war water
tofu which means women that dive and
they yeah they taught themselves how to
how to spear fish and they do it in all
of their traditional clothing using
these amazing and made goggles and if
you go back to the gallery a second yeah
you can see on the right yeah that's one
of the day that's a good shot thank you
very much yeah that's some using a 35
mil lens I could quite like to use that
lens for portraits which is a bit
unusual but it gives that a very like
visceral kind of looming in feeling you
wouldn't go if I sometimes like if you
shoot portraits with a 50 mil 85 no one
dreadmill it flattens everything yeah
yeah bit here like you know you get
these warts that are really like a
popping out at you yeah there's depth on
this for sure exactly you get every pore
in the skin so
yeah I think kind of that that's
something that I've been trying to build
into my photography is using unusual
techniques that might not be applied to
conservation photography so I've been
getting some tips for example from like
a good friend of mine is a very high-end
fashion photographer and he's just
giving me some very simple tips that he
uses and I'm like well what if we can
apply some of these two environmental
photography like how cool would that be
so that if you go back I'll give you
another example so if you go back to the
wildlife tourism section and scroll down
scroll down okay
left yeah middle middle image that
orangutan there yeah so this image was
taken using Christmas tree lights which
was just an idea that I came up with um
so it's holding Christmas tree lights in
front of your lens and then shooting
through them and you get this very cool
kind of lens flare type feel to it and
again it just adds something different
to an image without without that I think
I've shown it to a lot of photographers
and it's either kind of love it or know
that a lot of them are like that it's
ridiculous that's such a stupid idea it
would be much better without those four
but actually I think it adds something a
little bit different yeah I see what
you're saying cuz otherwise it'd be kind
of just fur on the left yeah exactly
exactly um and yeah he's he's given me
sort of lots of other tools and ideas
that I'm now experimenting with and one
of the big things is is lighting every
fashion and commercial photographer
knows that photography is is all about
lighting but what if you can take those
lighting principles that are used for
commercial photography and am either and
apply them to environmental photography
I think that'd be really cool so now I I
always travel with sort of like a basic
softbox kit um in order to try and get
so if you go if you go back and it
really does make a huge
scroll up really does make a massive
difference
how are your imagery looks I don't know
might be in the environmental section
this is good because I want to talk
about what's on the right top right yeah
that that shot so there we have the
backlighting from the Morning Sun but
then I just have my director on the
right who is using this like very cool
lightweight a softbox system which I use
the godox ad 8200 and you carry that
around in the bear I carry it around
it's only like it's like this big but
jeez they're powerful they're they're
like almost as powerful as pro photos
but also probably about 20% of the price
nice and and they're just yeah it's so
so I'll have that and I will have like a
speedlight as well so then you can have
Biff fill in but sometimes of course you
don't you don't have time for this like
yeah saying only that my moment might be
gone in a second I used to have a more
scattergun approach to photography just
yeah just just try and cover the scene
as much as possible and now I try and go
in with a little bit more of a plan like
I would rather come away from a scene
with one or two shots that I love yes
opposed to 10 shots that are good that
makes a lot of sense yeah so this was a
this was a shot that I I had in mind
when I was approaching this is that the
Borneo orangutan survival foundation in
Kalimantan and in Borneo and and I've
seen these shots of the orangutans being
pushed around in wheelbarrows a lot and
they're often shot with an 85mm lens or
you know 70 to 200 long lens compress
being pushed down a platform and I
thought actually you know that's used
this this 35 mil 16 to 35 again which
also just gives it much more of a kind
of visceral feeling I really like using
a close focus wide-angle for
environmental photography because you're
there it's like you're part of the scene
yeah versus just a flat distant zoomed
in you want people not just to see the
animal but to actually be the animal
yeah
and like if you go back to I'll give
them maybe some more examples of this as
they go yeah yeah that down the left
that rat if you go up with it so this no
sorry close that yeah that one yeah I
think what was what is that I was almost
shot with a fisheye actually what sin is
nose um it's actually not coming out of
its nose it's coming out of a of its
harness which is behind its head it just
looks like it's coming out of its nose
which is a bit unfortunate but these are
rats in Cambodia that have been trained
to sniff out land mines oh my goodness
yeah and these rats oh they're saving
lives out there and cuz Cambodia again
still recovering from war and it's got
millions of these land mines still then
all the field was scattered all over the
whole country so they're using these
rats that can now sniff them out so I
covered that as a story for Asian
Geographic magazine but yeah I think
that was that was using a fisheye lens
it means that you can get really close
to the subject yeah and it means that
yeah again like it like I was saying you
you want people not just to see it but
to actually be it and that's something
that I have applied to the lot of the
wildlife tourism images so if we go back
to wildlife tourism yeah yeah maybe yeah
top on top middle top metal there same
thing I think that shot had maybe 16 mil
and I think it's just a very powerful
tool I think actually because I I
started a lot of my photography was
underwater yeah and underwater the rule
is to get close and then get closer
again because you want to minimize the
amount of water between yourself and the
subject okay so and that's in order to
get the the Crispus it crispest image I
see and and the the best colors I said
that's why I underwater photographers
shoot almost everything with it with a
fisheye lens because you want to be you
want to be shooting from here yeah if I
if I shoot you the subject me to you
murky mix your way yeah you get too many
particles too much water between you but
you if you actually get on top of
you're subject then you'll get the the
best result that's all so that was when
I started applying it more to
environmental photography - quite
powerful powerful effects but I think it
you you're constantly changing it you do
want to have your own style and your own
signature but you also don't want to
wanna just stick to that you don't want
to pigeon-holed yourself yeah you got to
reinvent a little bit that's what yeah
which is why I say which is why I've
started using slightly different I've
actually got my camera bag here yeah I
wanted to ask about that you want me to
bring it up yeah I don't know if I've
got a lot of my my bits and bobs in here
this might just be more oh yeah no I've
stripped a lot of I've stripped a lot of
stuff out but I came here so here's a
little tour of my stripped down camera
bag do one here don't bring this up like
this
Thanks all right so 5d Mark four which I
upgraded to recently I had a wonderful
donor people are amazing like I have so
much support for my work because that's
always one of the biggest challenges is
how do you actually fund this mm-hmm
and it's one one of the things that I
struggle with the most is is actually
getting funding for these projects but
sometimes you know people will contact
me and be like you know I saw that you
were interested in a new camera like
maybe I can help you out and you know
some guy then put two thousand dollars
in my account the next day that's
awesome that's nice trying someone
bought me a GoPro seven yesterday which
is really nice like it you know I feel
kind of bad about it but as long as you
use it you got to use it as long as you
use it for the for the right purposes
yeah then that's then that's okay I
think so
then lenses I don't have my I just
bought the Tamron 150 to 600 which is
amazing the G goodness but that's a
beast variable sound what would be here
yeah yeah the image stabilization is
insane like you're shooting handheld six
hundred mil at 140th and still getting
bad images Wow it's beautiful and it's
not that expensive the main
consideration for me as always of course
budget but also weight yeah everything
comes with
me wherever I go yeah so I have to have
that pen you know what you know what
it's like you're like Albert and I
wouldn't it be nice if I had this prime
lens or this prime lens or I can't
travel without this so then it starts
growing very quickly so I just have to
kind of limit myself to this camera bag
and yeah I have another small bag for
for lighting yes ah
and then my clothes and that's that's
pretty much all I travel with so are you
are you out there like with this on your
back and then you know the lighting one
on your front
the lighting one goes in my suitcase
with my clothes okay so I have those
yeah those two bags but again like I
said a very simple softbox yeah the
godox speedlights and then a couple of
light little tools that I'm using like
the Christmas tree lights or like lens
flare sticks and then do you make a day
bag when you go out and then yeah a day
bag a gadget plus plus this camera bag
so it's like camping it's like
backpacking a little bit yeah well yeah
exactly very very heavy backpacks so
unless we got so we have I just bought
this lens this would I just bought this
two weeks ago I was using the Canon
24-105 but it was the old one and it
just wasn't good enough so I have
changed to the Tamron after being so
impressed with the 150 to 600 and
particularly the image stabilization and
image quality and I read reviews about
this which is the 2470 nice F 2.8 and it
has image stabilization which the Canon
one doesn't have okay yeah so I just
took my first shots on this the other
day so I don't want to say too much
because I haven't looked at the images
yet but I've heard very good things so
this is my all-purpose lens I wish I had
out my recent European wildlife tourism
trip unfortunate didn't this is my
workhorse which is the best thing I ever
bought which is the 1635 ZL Callen yeah
1535 l very nice just a wonderful event
and probably 60% of images you'll see on
my website were taken with this awesome
yep awesome
focus wine angle yeah that well that's
my main one but would be interesting to
see when I start using the Twenty twenty
four seventy where if I like that that
maybe that will become my main lens
macro yeah 100 mil love-love-love for
portraits oh let me see if we go to some
bee galleries maybe wildlife tourism
there's got to be some Oh actually the
one I showed you earlier of the
orangutan with the Christmas tree lights
that was shot with the yeah that shot
with a hundred mil hazing did the
quality prime lenses as we as we know
the quality is what is that much better
they're just not yeah that practical for
these sorts of jobs so then if you go
back to the galleries I'll just get to
give some examples of lenses that I'm
using
oh no sorry stay on wildlife tourism is
fine oh yeah that's nice snake that
snake was shot yeah that's 100 mil macro
and then if you go up oh yeah and then
the orangutan in the middle that's no
sorry not that one the one above it yeah
that one that's again using that close
focus wide angles that's gang I'm
probably only a couple of feet away from
this orangutan yeah I think I think it
you're really seeing his world there
yeah that's crazy
that's probably all he sees like yeah
that's all he seen for the last 13 years
unfortunately was rescued from the
boxing shows in Thailand and then
because there's nowhere to put these
rescue during a tonnes I'm not the time
they end up languishing in in cells like
this or cages like this so the NGO who
were who are working and have all these
rescued or anger turns are working to
find them suitable release areas but
this is hugely expensive as you can
imagine and it's not it's not so easy
you can't just take all these animals
that were rescue from the wildlife
tourism industry and then just release
them into the wild because they would
never survived so a lot of the time
places that will take them on a left in
this predicament of what to actually do
with the animals hmm are they ever
released
well they once there have gone through
some sort of process or is it like they
stay in this area that has monitored
forever they can go to pre-release sites
or like semi wild locations so a shot
that I took recently which is this is my
favorite shot I've taken if you go back
to the galleries I know I know that okay
wildlife at the top okay
and yes okay on the left yeah that shot
of the orangutan my goodness mother and
baby so kind so that was one of the
rescued orangutans from Thailand and
that that particular item was actually
suitable for release so this is a
semi-wild location and then she just
gave birth
this little baby then if you can see the
the butterfly as well that's landed on
the mother's head oh I thought that was
like a tag that's awesome raisi right so
that's a nice kind of story of hope
there and they they do have all these
other animals that they're hoping to put
in these semi wild locations soon I'm
sorry I digressed so that was the
hundred mil and then fifty mil of course
like I say if I could shoot everything
on prime lenses I would yeah oh yes yes
this is another this is the new lens
that I haven't used yet as well I just
went back to the UK and stocked up 35
mil f2 I see this yeah 3035 f2 because I
was shooting everything on my 16th 235
ya are shooting a lot at 35 and then I
read really good reports about about
this lens and I was like wow if you're
shooting so much 35 and then you can get
even better quality with a prime lens
yeah might as well
let's give it a go it'll be interesting
to see if it is a big step up in quality
from just using the 1635 which of course
gives them all more flexibility so do
you run
when you do that like will you shoot a
test image of like a prime versus a zoom
and you'll see okay here's artifacting
here or so you don't get the light
quality on this one and all this I think
I'm not one of those hugely technical
photographers yeah I mean I go by feel a
lot and I will just know if I take that
lens out for a couple of days and I will
just know what feels better totally yeah
so I'm not someone who is you know could
tell you about lens dynamics and how
they work an offer I couldn't take it
apart and put it back together again
I've got no idea but I know what I like
and this is um this is a little again
try just using slightly different
techniques so this is here have you
heard of these the mayor optic this is
now in the 1950s this is a lens here yep
you know and it gives this soap bubble
back a look to it so yeah the popper
bokeh is all these tiny little circles
and bubbles yeah looks really cool so
any light that is blurred out in the
foreground or background will look a bit
different with this one and well
everything looks a little bit softer as
well it looks much more filmic awesome
I do sometimes find that these lenses
the new ones are so good they're so
sharp yeah was actually again with with
film you want things to look a little
bit softer more forgiving mm hmm hmm so
that's something that I would love to oh
I did take a shot with this I can show
you an example if you go back to
wildlife tourism it you might not you
might not even notice the difference
scroll down there should be a black and
white baby orangutan baby orangutan my
website Shamus good shot should be Oh No
okay sorry scrap that it's a really good
shot I should put on my website but yeah
it's just yeah it looks like it's short
on film I feel you I shoot mostly film
now I love the characteristics and the
oddities of different stocks and I like
the you know the grunge enos sometimes
you know or you leave it on the Sun for
a little too
and you get a look I love that stuff you
know otherwise it's like very clean and
just like sterile and like this is it
you know sterile that's a good way of
putting it yeah
exactly that's why I can how I sometimes
feel with the modern lenses but it's a
it's a lot more of a risk isn't it
because you can always make you can
always use Photoshop to make things look
a little bit more vintage absolutely on
you but you can't necessarily use it to
make it sharper yeah and I'm again I
just do like random lay oh that's a nice
scene there I'll take my time and shoot
this but if you're doing what you're
doing like having a digital camera is
like it's it's so necessary yeah yeah
yeah completely so that's why I always
err on the on the side of course
sometimes if I have a little bit more
time and I want to experiment then I I
might use that if you shot something you
have to get it in the can yes yeah yeah
yeah in the can and then you can get
creative that makes sense this is
something I'd really recommend anyone
who's watching this so a flashlight
these are amazing so yeah they're just
just little on camera camera video like
that's nice yeah they're great and you
can umm so if you go to again I'm not
sure if this will have been yeah yeah I
just use it as a little spotlight um I
was just in the Czech Republic
photographing Python vet for a film I'm
making about pythons and the exotic pet
trade and just yeah he was in an
operating room and I just put this this
light right above him and it gives that
some studio feel very stark it's super
small yeah get a couple of these place
them in different places use them to to
accentuate something you know you want
to be like yeah it feels like the things
made of tank metal like you just drop it
and be all good yeah yeah yeah they're
they're very sturdy that's awesome so
you don't need like crazy big setups you
can just just get a bit inventive and
this was this may be a hundred bucks 80
bucks something like that and just a
very useful thing to have
in your in your kit bank what else you
get that might be I have taken a few
things out but I think yeah some filters
you know speed like nothing nothing too
exciting I don't have my lighting bag
with me but yeah should give you guys a
sort of general feel for what I have in
there challenge trying to like walk
through anything really nice and light
yeah
and then when they catch and they're
like 16 kilos trying to pack as light as
possible as there's a constant challenge
yeah man Aaron I really really
appreciate you coming out here it's been
cool learning about what you got in your
bag and like all the different things
that you have to go through to get the
shots that you go through and everything
and all the tips that you've given us
that's really really awesome man thank
you no I really appreciate you talking
to me about it this is something that I
want to do is I want to spend a bit more
time you can get really carried away
just being out on location and what I
realize I need to do is become a little
bit more commercial about it which is
why I'm in America at the moment as well
as making a film about pythons and the
exotic pet ray but it's so we can meet
people like yourself and to try and make
what I am doing more of a commercial
enterprise
I suppose so like one thing that I'm
looking at at the moment is um it's
we're calling it an executive producer
experience so what this is is a way of
us because currently sitting on all
these incredible stories that need to be
told
yeah but the biggest challenge is its
funding them filmmaking is you know it's
not a cheap business absolutely no no
and when you take into account all your
crew and travel and we always do
everything we can to keep costs a
minimum like you would not believe the
budgets that we can kind of work with so
one way that we're looking to try and
fund some of these is by bringing
longboard on our shoots so it's like
okay we are currently working on this
orangutan tourism film were working on a
film about elephant conservation we're
pitching a film about chimpanzee
conservation which is fascinating it's
such a fascinating story about what's
happening to chimpanzees they're just
been wiped out left right and center by
you know traditional meds and the exotic
pet trade being you know deforestation
so we have a sitting on all of these
ideas so it's like okay well why not
bring people out who can come on board
with the film and they're executive
producers on the project but actually
they get to join us on shoot and have
the experience of a lifetime oh that's
awesome
they get to come to to the jungles of
Africa where we want to go to Liberia
and we want to go to Guinea to shoot
this documentary about chimps or we want
it you know we're about to go to a
voodoo festival and burn in oh my god I
just so down for that yet people to come
along and come onboard and their funding
is helping us to tell these usually
important stories and they get of course
credits and they get to have the
experience of a lifetime where do people
go to well this is something I'm just
developing at the moment yeah of the
reason why I'm in LA so but if people go
to my website which is just Aaron
tchaikovsky calm and just get in touch
with me we have a slate of projects that
is changing all of the time and really
looking for people who might be
interested in coming on board and you
can actually help us get these out out
there and come join us on on trips like
I cannot even begin to tell you some of
the experiences that we have whether
you're face to face with a blue whale or
whether you're releasing you know
pangolins and orangutans and the jungles
of Borneo or you're at this voodoo
festival in Africa like this is this is
kind of why do and this is this is kind
of my life and I would love to open this
up to other people and for them to come
and explore it and enjoy it with me that
sounds incredible I I like to travel at
least once a year outside of the country
so I might be Hinn you up on that as
well
come for sure for sure yeah absolutely
absolutely and now I can happily send
you like more details or some of the
projects that were working on and
fantastically yeah it's not always yeah
I always have to like put that caveat in
I'm like the things we do things that
are very rustic right yeah it often
involves you know like a very basic
accommodation and food and traveling on
buses across the continent and like
whatever it's a story no I'm not doing
this for the money I can tell you that
much like we if we can get a bit of
budget to make it film we will make the
film whatever whatever happens because I
just want to tell these stories and like
wildlife is being absolutely decimated
laughs Ryan centre we're in the myths of
a sixth mass extinction event you know
whether it's exotic pets traditional
meds and overfishing pollution if
animals are being hit from all sides so
whatever we can do I think as filmmakers
and photographers and working in the
media to get these stories out there
then that's you know let's let's do it
that's awesome so I'd love to welcome
you on on any shoots that we have
absolutely heck yeah man any other any
other places you wanna is Aaron
Joukowsky comm any other spots that
that's the best place like seven but
old-school I like to kind of keep my
website quite updated and that's the
sort of central bulletin for my work but
I am also on yeah on Instagram and
Facebook as well whether it's a personal
or professional cool then I used those
the platforms that I use the most over
the people just just drop me an email
info Aaron Tchaikovsky comm Aaron thank
you so much man thank you special
pleasure thanks for coming out